vitro fertilization what used to be
called test tube babies right
frozen eggs are frozen yeah Frozen
embryos it could be there for years
sometimes more than a decade well if you
believe that the uh Soul enters at the
point of conception they have souls and
yet do you ever uh you know have the
millions of people walking around today
who used to be in that state do they
ever say yeah it was really boring you
know floating around getting really
bored no they never report that so it
doesn't seem to be a problem for that
yeah yeah we also have people have been
legally dead for up to an hour or so and
if you believe the soul leaves when the
body stops functioning uh again they
don't really report you know being in
some kind of boring condition so I don't
think it's a problem also because if
there is a soul it's obviously not a
physical thing because otherwise we
could detect it with science so it must
be outside space and time so I think
whether it's a day or you know a minute
or a day or 100 years shouldn't make any
difference right that's true if it's
gone for an hour it's gone for it if if
it's that attached to the actual
physical being then it should be able to
come back so really you guys if people
are able to be the
thought out
hypothetically back into existence we
might find we would learn a lot about if
there are souls or not
maybe yeah I mean my view is it's
completely compatible with just about
any religion there might be one or two
exceptions that uh is it the Jehovah's
Witnesses or one of the groups that
doesn't do blood transfusions that could
be a problem for us removing the blood
but apart from that I mean if you're a
Christian uh it would seem to me that
you'd want to do this because first of
all why are you in such a rush to get
your Eternal reward don't you want to do
some more good works or save some Souls
that kind of thing yeah it's a bit
selfish to take off at the yeah just
earliest opportunity right yeah Buzz out
yeah you have one stroke and then you
leave that's kind of soft and uh Judaism
too I think is actually very Pro uh
pro-living and you know life is
basically good you stick around and do
good works so yeah my Jewish buddies
they'll Mill around forever dude if
there's some opportunity you know Jews
love to do stuff and create you know be
part of things for sure so so it's
really not going to lose them no it's I
mean the way I think of it is chronix is
really an extension of emergency
medicine it's not something kind of
strange thing about dead people because
they're not really dead it's just an
extension of emergency medicine it's a
doctor saying I just can't do anything
more for this person right now and we're
saying well let's not just destroy them
by putting them in an oven or the ground
given to us let us treat them stop them
getting worse and give the future a
chance at giving them more life that
seems like the reasonable conservative
thing to do yeah it seems like
yeah I mean I consider myself a
Christian and I believe that I'm I'm
down for it you know
um yeah do you feel like it's like do
you feel like it's like divinely intend
like there's Divine intention behind
this or do you think that it would be
like divinely frowned upon I guess and
you may have already just answered that
well I don't I don't think either if
there is a God out there uh I don't see
God objecting to us uh creating the
internet for instance or uh electric
vehicles or even old-fashioned Vehicles
so I think if there is a God then for
the most part that God lets us use our
own intelligence uh god-given
intelligence if you like yeah
um and what we do is up to us and what
we do hopefully we'll do good things
with it but I don't think there is a
list of things that we we mustn't do
it's more a matter of you know let's do
the right thing let's do good things
this is a good thing this is about
saving lives about giving people more
life and able to do more good things
yeah and maybe God would be impressed
too God would be like dang you guys
figured this out yeah I think that'd be
pretty cool too you got off the planet
69 then it's the one on the moon now
you're bringing people back to that's
pretty cool you guys are doing good
going guys yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one